well
certainly was the most unconventional
manifesto launch that we've seen for a
long time
not just the setting the movie's return
nice for a soap opera and there was a
bit of panto too when michael gove
turned up with some guys in masks
but um the manifesto itself pretty
conventional
on the first page a budget
responsibility lock
talking about fiscal policy using the
manifesto process to
deal with a negative rather than
projecting the positive we haven't seen
that before
conservatives were cock-a-hoop at the
idea that labour were making such a
defensive move but in the end
interesting confident performance by ed
miliband
uh combative against uh the conservative
party um some conservatives worrying
that they've underestimated the
labour leader now and at the end of it
all
a challenge for the conservatives over
one crucial thing which is the idea that
they're spending some of their fiscal
credibility
and opened up an opportunity for a a
party that
has had problems with fiscal credibility
to try to retain it
but is it too late